hei nama aku Olivia Lanes dan selamat datang kembali di Quantum Computing in Practice, ini adalah episode dua tentang Quantum
circuit, kita akan membahas beberapa topik dalam kuliah hari ini tapi yang ingin aku buat kamu pahami adalah tiga hal berikut, satu apa itu
komputer kuantum IBM sebenarnya supaya setidaknya kamu punya gambaran kasar di pikiran kamu tentang apa yang kamu lakukan ketika kamu mengirim pekerjaan ke salah satunya melalui
cloud, dua apa itu Qiskit, apa itu Primitives dan bagaimana kita bisa menggunakannya untuk membuat dan mengeksekusi Quantum circuit
kita juga akan membahas secara tingkat tinggi berbagai jenis prosesor IBM Quantum yang tersedia dan apa yang membedakan satu dari yang lain dan tiga
terakhir workflow khas yang kita ikuti untuk menjalankan eksperimen dalam skala besar, ini termasuk memilih Primitives terbaik
untuk kasus penggunaan kamu, memetakan masalah ke Quantum circuit dan menerapkan error suppression dan mitigation yang memungkinkan
kita mendapatkan sebanyak mungkin daya dari mesin-mesin ini, ada banyak informasi di sini tapi tetaplah bersama aku
karena segera kita akan menyatukannya semua dalam konteks beberapa contoh nyata, pertama mari kita bahas secara singkat tentang qubit dan hardware Quantum
yang sebenarnya, sebagai seorang eksperimentalis aku bisa berjanji bahwa itu menarik sekali dan sangat membantu menghubungkan titik-titik untuk
memvisualisasikan apa yang sebenarnya terjadi ketika pekerjaan dikirim ke komputer kuantum melalui cloud, prosesor yang
akan kita gunakan dibangun dengan qubit transmon superkonduktor, ini seperti apa prosesor kuantum IBM kecil
sekarang kotak-kotak kecil ini adalah qubit itu sendiri jadi ada total lima pada chip ini, transmon
itu sendiri adalah kapasitor dan terdiri dari dua pelat logam yang terhubung secara paralel dengan induktor nonlinear yang disebut
Josephson junction tapi untuk melihat Josephson junction kamu sebenarnya harus zoom in bahkan lebih jauh, itu dibuat dari dua
lapisan logam superkonduktor yang saling tumpang tindih dan di mana dua potongan tersebut tumpang tindih dan bersentuhan adalah junctionnya, sebuah Josephson
Junction adalah elemen yang bisa digunakan untuk membuat atom buatan dengan beberapa level energi dan kita mengisolasi
dua level energi terbawah sebagai Qubit State kita, garis-garis berkelok di sini merepresentasikan resonator microwave
pada dasarnya saluran transmisi 2D yang terhubung ke qubit, sekarang ketika kita memprogram sebuah gate itu pada dasarnya setara dengan memilih
pulsa microwave yang dikalibrasi dengan sangat tepat dan frekuensi amplitudo bentuk dan durasi spesifik dari pulsa-pulsa tersebut membuat
qubit melakukan hal-hal tertentu, instruksi untuk pulsa microwave pergi dari komputer kamu ke cloud dan
kemudian dibaca dan diinterpretasikan oleh elektronik kontrol suhu ruangan yang mengambil instruksi-instruksi tersebut dan secara fisik
menghasilkan pulsa-pulsa tersebut, kita menyebutnya pulsa microwave karena semuanya masuk dalam bandwidth frekuensi microwave
yang sekitar 1 GHz, setelah kotak kontrol suhu ruangan membuat pulsa-pulsa tersebut mereka melakukan perjalanan melalui kabel
ke dalam dilution refrigerator dan akhirnya ke chip Quantum kita, sinyal masuk ke resonator melalui
wire bond pada pad-pad ini dan kemudian mengalir turun saluran transmisi ke qubit kita, sekarang aku tahu ini semua mungkin
sedikit teknis dan detail ini tidak krusial untuk dipahami untuk ke depannya tapi aku berharap sekarang kamu
semua setidaknya bisa membayangkan sistem fisik yang akan kalian semua segera berinteraksi dengannya, jadi di mana komputer kuantum ini
sebenarnya berada? well IBM memiliki puluhan komputer kuantum di seluruh dunia dan kita baru-baru ini meng-upgrade armada kita untuk
hanya berisi prosesor 100 plus qubit, seperti yang aku sebutkan di pelajaran sebelumnya beberapa diantaranya berlokasi di
IBM Quantum data center di Upstate New York, sistem-sistem tersebut di-deploy di seluruh cloud untuk digunakan semua orang dan beberapa
diantaranya adalah sistem on-premise khusus lengkap dengan semua elektronik untuk membuatnya bekerja yang mendukung mitra-mitra kita
dalam IBM quantum network, sekarang mari kita bahas Qiskit yang merupakan software development kit open-source IBM
yang dirancang untuk bekerja pada komputer kuantum, dari sekarang aku akan merujuk ini sebagai Qiskit SDK, ada juga
ekosistem Qiskit yang merupakan kumpulan tutorial software dan fungsi yang membangun atau memperluas fungsionalitas inti Qiskit serta
Qiskit runtime yang merupakan layanan Quantum Computing dan model pemrograman yang memungkinkan pengguna merancang dan secara efisien
mengeksekusi workload Quantum mereka menggunakan Qiskit Primitives dan sebuah Primitive pada dasarnya adalah blok bangunan kecil yang
bisa kamu gunakan untuk merancang circuit yang lebih besar atau sebuah pekerjaan, dua Primitives yang paling penting bagi kita adalah
sampler dan estimator yang akan kita bahas lebih dalam sebentar lagi, kalau kamu belum mengunduh dan menginstal
Qiskit SDK, tidak ada waktu yang lebih baik dari sekarang, Qiskit 1.0 baru-baru ini dirilis dan lebih berperforma dan
stabil dari sebelumnya, jadi bagi kamu yang baru mulai kamu datang di waktu yang tepat, bagi kamu
yang sudah familiar dengan Qiskit kamu perlu mengunduh dan menginstal ulang versi terbaru, kita merekomendasikan menggunakan
pip untuk menginstal Qiskit dan Qiskit runtime dan menjalankannya melalui Jupyter notebook di browser web pilihanmu, jadi kamu juga akan perlu
menginstal jupyter notebook atau JupyterLab kalau kamu belum melakukannya, alat-alat ini semua gratis dan kamu
bisa menjalankannya di mesin lokal kamu sendiri tanpa biaya, pastikan untuk menambahkan Qiskit dengan opsi visualization
dependencies sehingga bisa bekerja dengan Jupyter dan memungkinkan kamu memplot sesuatu, kamu juga perlu mengatur virtual Python environment dan ada
instruksi cara melakukan ini di halaman instal Qiskit yang terhubung di sini, setelah kamu familiar dengan Qiskit dan kamu
siap menjalankan pekerjaan di komputer kuantum nyata kamu perlu mendaftar di quantum.com dan membuat IBM Quantum
API token dan ada juga link untuk itu di sini, walkthrough terperinci tentang cara melakukan ini ikuti semua
instruksi di halaman dokumentasi kita seperti yang aku sebutkan atau kamu bisa menonton video instalasi coding with Qiskit di sini
keduanya terhubung dan ada di deskripsi, sekarang kita hampir siap untuk mulai berbicara tentang Quantum
circuit, karena poin dari kursus ini adalah mengajar kalian semua cara scale up pekerjaan kalian untuk dijalankan pada skala 100 plus
qubit, aku percaya cara yang paling konstruktif untuk maju adalah dengan pertama-tama mempertimbangkan workflow keseluruhan yang akan kita ikuti dan cara termudah untuk
memahami workflow Quantum Computing yang khas adalah melalui Qiskit patterns, Qiskit patterns adalah kerangka konseptual yang memungkinkan pengguna menjalankan Quantum
workload dengan mengimplementasikan langkah-langkah tertentu dengan tooling modular, ini memungkinkan tugas Quantum Computing dilakukan oleh
infrastruktur komputasi heterogen yang kuat, langkah-langkah ini bisa dilakukan sebagai layanan dan bisa
memasukkan Resource Management yang memungkinkan komposabilitas mulus dari kemampuan baru seiring dikembangkannya, di sini
adalah langkah-langkah utama yang kemungkinan besar sudah dikenali oleh pengguna Qiskit berpengalaman, langkah pertama adalah pemetaan, langkah ini
memformalkan cara kita mengambil masalah umum yang kita minati dan mencari tahu cara memetakannya ke dalam komputer kuantum
dalam bentuk circuit, berikutnya kita mengoptimalkan, dalam langkah ini kita menggunakan transpiler Qiskit untuk merutekan dan menata
circuit ke hardware Quantum fisik yang sebenarnya, ini termasuk menerjemahkan gate-gate Quantum individual ke dalam sekuens
WEBVTT
operasi yang dilakukan pada hardware serta optimasi dalam tata letak gate-gate tersebut, berikutnya kita akan
mengeksekusi, Qiskit runtime Primitives menyediakan antarmuka ke IBM Quantum Hardware yang memungkinkan circuit yang telah ditranspilasi berjalan
langkah ini juga mencakup penggunaan teknik error suppression dan mitigation yang sebagian besar bisa diabstraksi dari pengguna, terakhir kita melakukan post-processing dalam
langkah ini data dari prosesor kuantum itu sendiri diproses memberikan pengguna hasil yang berguna dari masalah aslinya, pada dasarnya langkah ini
mencakup analisis lebih lanjut dari data yang diperoleh, sekarang kita siap untuk membahas fondasi dari program
kuantum yaitu Quantum circuit, semoga kamu sudah familiar dengan Quantum circuit tapi kalau belum kamu mungkin ingin terlebih dahulu melihat pelajaran
tiga tentang Quantum circuit yang merupakan bagian dari understanding quantum information and computation yang tertaut di bawah, kita hanya
akan memberikan refresher singkat di sini, sekarang sebuah Quantum circuit adalah jaringan gate dan pengukuran kuantum yang dihubungkan
oleh kabel yang merepresentasikan qubit, Quantum circuit bisa dibaca seperti not musik dari kiri ke kanan mulai dari
time zero yang paling jauh di sebelah kiri, qubit virtual artinya qubit yang belum ditugaskan ke qubit
fisik pada prosesor dicantumkan dalam urutan naik dari atas ke bawah, setelah kita mengatur circuit kita bisa menambahkan
gate ke sana, gate single qubit seperti gate Hadamard ini hanya mempengaruhi qubit yang kabelnya ditempatkan, gate multi qubit
seperti CNOT ini mempengaruhi dua atau lebih qubit yang dihubungkan oleh gate, di sini dalam contoh ini state qubit satu berubah
tergantung pada state qubit nol setelah semua gate diterapkan kita bisa melakukan pengukuran
yang menyebabkan hasil ditulis ke register klasik, satu karakteristik yang sangat penting dari
sebuah circuit adalah kedalamannya, kedalaman Quantum circuit adalah jumlah minimum layer dari gate kuantum yang dieksekusi secara
paralel yang diperlukan untuk menyelesaikan komputasi yang didefinisikan oleh circuit, untuk memperjelas gate Quantum bisa dieksekusi secara
paralel atau dengan kata lain pada waktu yang persis sama kapan pun mereka tidak memiliki qubit yang sama tetapi kalau dua atau lebih
gate bekerja pada qubit yang sama maka kita tidak bisa melakukannya secara paralel, kita terpaksa melakukannya satu demi satu karena gate Quantum membutuhkan waktu untuk
diimplementasikan, kedalaman sebuah circuit kira-kira sesuai dengan jumlah waktu yang diperlukan komputer kuantum untuk mengeksekusi
circuit tersebut, jadi mengetahui kedalaman circuit itu penting untuk mengetahui apakah itu bisa digunakan untuk dijalankan pada perangkat tertentu atau tidak, ini juga akan memberi tahu kita apakah
itu memiliki peluang yang baik untuk menghasilkan hasil yang akurat, berikutnya mari kita lanjutkan ke pemilihan prosesor Quantum, IBM
baru-baru ini merilis seluruh armada prosesor baru semuanya memiliki lebih dari 100 qubit dan kamu bisa login ke quantum.com untuk melihat
prosesor mana yang bisa kamu akses, prosesor semuanya dinamai berdasarkan burung karena alasan tertentu dan logo yang berbeda
merepresentasikan jenis prosesor yang berbeda, jadi misalnya yang ini merepresentasikan prosesor Eagle dan ikon ini adalah
Heron, nama prosesor spesifik juga ditemukan di atas, semuanya dinamai setelah kota tapi itu
tidak harus berarti prosesornya secara fisik berlokasi di kota tersebut, itu hanya nama-nama saja, jumlah qubit
EPPG dan CLOPS juga merupakan faktor yang semuanya tercantum, kita akan membahas masing-masing dari ini
qubit sekarang ini cukup jelas, qubit hanyalah jumlah total qubit yang tersedia untuk digunakan pada prosesor Quantum tunggal itu atau
QPU, EPPG adalah singkatan dari errors per layered gate yang mengukur rata-rata error proses gate dalam rantai berlapis dari
100 qubit, pada dasarnya kamu ingin ini sekecil mungkin, CLOPS adalah singkatan dari circuit layer operations per second dan
mengukur berapa banyak layer dari Quantum volume circuit yaitu circuit virtual yang bisa dieksekusi QPU per satuan waktu
semakin tinggi angkanya semakin cepat kita bisa menghitung, ini setara dengan apa arti FLOPS dalam komputasi klasik, sekarang
metrik yang berbeda ini mungkin lebih atau kurang penting tergantung pada area aplikasi spesifik yang kamu minati, berikutnya mari kita bahas secara tingkat tinggi
pemetaan ke Quantum circuit, langkah pertama adalah langkah pemetaan yang pada dasarnya menjawab pertanyaan bagaimana
aku menerjemahkan masalahku ke dalam Quantum circuit yang bisa dijalankan di Quantum Hardware, tidak diragukan lagi
pemetaan adalah masalah yang sulit dan ini adalah area penelitian yang aktif, kadang-kadang hanya bisa mengambil masalah komputasi
dan membuat sekuens gate kuantum yang membantu menyelesaikannya adalah bagian yang paling sulit, tidak ada metode anti-gagal
yang menjamin keberhasilan tapi ada panduan yang direkomendasikan dan contoh masalah yang sudah kita tahu cara
memetakannya, panduan pertama adalah membiarkan komputer klasik melakukan pekerjaan apa pun yang lebih baik mereka lakukan sendiri,
tes yang mudah untuk komputer klasik mungkin tidak akan mendapat manfaat dari komputer kuantum, komputer kuantum adalah untuk masalah yang secara klasik sulit,
tentu saja kalau ini adalah pertama kalinya kamu menggunakan Qiskit atau komputer kuantum jangan khawatir tentang menemukan masalah yang secara komputasi kompleks, pecah
menjadi masalah yang lebih kecil yang bisa kamu pelajari untuk ditangani sebelum langsung ke proyek skala utilitas, berikutnya terjemahkan
hasil untuk masalah kamu yang ingin kamu ukur atau pahami menjadi masalah nilai ekspektasi atau masalah sampling
untuk sebagian besar jenis masalah ini pada dasarnya sesuai dengan menghitung fungsi biaya, fungsi biaya adalah
fungsi spesifik masalah yang mendefinisikan tujuan masalah sebagai sesuatu yang harus diminimalkan atau dimaksimalkan dan mereka bisa
digunakan untuk melihat seberapa baik trial state atau solusi bekerja sehubungan dengan tujuan tersebut
gagasan ini bisa diterapkan ke berbagai aplikasi dalam kimia, machine learning, keuangan, optimasi dan sebagainya
juga ingat bahwa hardware yang akan kamu gunakan memiliki topologi tertentu, beberapa qubit tidak terhubung
dan ada yang terhubung dan pada akhirnya kamu perlu memetakan masalah kamu ke circuit yang merepresentasikan ini, prosesor IBM Quantum
menggunakan apa yang disebut topologi heavy hex yang pada dasarnya setara dengan koneksi qubit dalam kisi heksagonal yang
akan kita bahas lebih lanjut nanti dalam kursus, untuk saat ini hal terpenting yang perlu diingat adalah bahwa tahap ini memerlukan
latihan, kamu perlu memiliki pemahaman yang baik tidak hanya tentang masalah kamu tapi juga kemampuan
hardware kuantum dan kita akan melalui contoh dan kasus penggunaan spesifik nanti untuk melihat bagaimana ini bisa diseimbangkan dengan terbaik
sekarang mari kita bahas cara mengoptimalkan circuit untuk hardware yang kita pilih, tujuan keseluruhan dari
langkah optimasi adalah memetakan semua qubit virtual dari circuit kita ke qubit nyata yang sebenarnya di suatu tempat pada
topologi prosesor, nama permainannya adalah mengurangi error sebanyak mungkin, untuk melakukan ini kita pertama-tama perlu
merutekan dan menata circuit kita secara efisien, hal pertama yang perlu diingat adalah tidak semua qubit terhubung seperti
yang sudah aku katakan beberapa sebenarnya cukup jauh satu sama lain pada chip jadi kita perlu mengurangi atau menghilangkan interaksi jarak
jauh kapan pun memungkinkan, kamu bisa menerapkan serangkaian swap gate antara qubit yang berdekatan untuk memindahkan informasi
qubit ke mana-mana tapi swap gate itu mahal dan rentan terhadap error jadi mungkin ada cara yang lebih baik untuk melakukan ini, tata letak berikutnya
WEBVTT
dan routing adalah proses iteratif dan mereka menetapkan qubit virtual ke circuit kamu pada qubit fisik pada
hardware, kamu bisa melakukan ini secara manual tapi ada juga tools di Qiskit yang bisa membuat rekomendasi untuk tata letak
qubit fisik berdasarkan perkiraan error rate, berikutnya kita bisa menyusun sekuens dari gate satu qubit yang bekerja pada qubit yang sama
menjadi gate tunggal dan kita juga terkadang bisa menghilangkan gate yang tidak diperlukan atau kombinasi gate, misalnya
beberapa kombinasi gate bisa dikurangi menjadi kombinasi yang lebih sederhana dan terkadang kombinasi gate bahkan
setara hanya dengan operator identitas sederhana jadi kita bisa menghilangkannya begitu saja, kamu bisa melakukan ini secara otomatis menggunakan
transpiler Qiskit atau kamu bisa melakukannya secara manual atas dasar gate demi gate kalau kamu punya alasan yang bagus untuk melakukannya dan kamu ingin
lebih banyak kontrol, setelah kita meningkatkan tata letak circuit routing dan jumlah gate baik secara manual maupun menggunakan Qiskit transpiler
kita biasanya ingin memvisualisasikan circuit kita untuk memastikan bahwa timing dari semua gate masuk akal, ada argumen yang bisa kamu tandai di transpiler untuk
memvisualisasikan timeline circuit kamu dan memastikan semuanya sejajar seperti yang kamu harapkan, sekarang mari kita bahas tentang error
suppression, error suppression mengacu pada berbagai teknik yang mengubah circuit selama kompilasi untuk meminimalkan error
berbeda dari error mitigation yang terjadi setelah circuit sudah dijalankan dan kita akan membahas itu segera, dua bentuk paling umum dari
error suppression yang kita manfaatkan adalah dynamical decoupling dan Pauli twirling, akan ada beberapa
detail teknis di sini tapi kamu selalu bisa merujuk kembali ke sini nanti, jadi yang pertama, dynamical decoupling digunakan untuk
secara efektif membatalkan beberapa noise yang mempengaruhi qubit dengan menerapkan serangkaian gate yang bersama-sama berjumlah ke
operasi identitas seperti sekuens XX dan yang efek bersihnya adalah untuk kira-kira membatalkan saluran noise yang mempengaruhi
qubit, Pauli twirling adalah cara menyisipkan gate acak untuk menyederhanakan rata-rata noise, keacakan membantu
mencegah efek dari error yang berbeda menumpuk secepat dan juga membuat noise lebih mudah untuk dikarakterisasi
sekarang metode ini juga membentuk dasar dari teknik error mitigation dan kita akan membahas itu nanti
sekali lagi ada banyak informasi di sini dan jangan khawatir kalau tidak semuanya langsung meresap, untungnya banyak dari ini bisa dilakukan secara otomatis menggunakan
transpiler Qiskit, transpilasi memang bisa tricky tapi transpilasi adalah langkah yang sangat krusial untuk mencapai utilitas dalam skala besar
sehingga memerlukan banyak trial and error untuk dikuasai dan mendapatkan hasil terbaik, sekarang aku mau mengambil jeda singkat
untuk membahas transpiler Qiskit dan kemampuannya sedikit lebih banyak, aku akan melakukan ini di tingkat yang sangat tinggi dan kita akan masuk ke detail dan melihat
beberapa contoh nanti, secara umum transpilasi adalah proses penulisan ulang circuit input yang diberikan untuk cocok
dengan topologi dan perangkat Quantum spesifik dan mengoptimalkan circuit untuk eksekusi dan ketahanan terhadap noise, ini juga
menulis ulang circuit yang diberikan ke dalam gate basis dari prosesor Quantum spesifik yang telah kamu pilih untuk digunakan, Qiskit memiliki empat
pipeline transpilasi bawaan dan kecuali kamu sudah familiar dengan optimasi Quantum circuit aku sangat menyarankan menggunakan salah satu dari
pipeline bawaan tersebut, secara default transpiler mencakup enam langkah ini yaitu initialization
layout routing translation optimization dan scheduling, sekarang initialization mengacu pada
pass awal yang diperlukan sebelum kita mulai menanamkan circuit ke backend, ini biasanya melibatkan
unrolling instruksi kustom dan mengkonversi circuit menjadi hanya gate satu dan dua qubit, tahap layout menerapkan
pemetaan tata letak qubit virtual dalam circuit ke qubit fisik pada backend, routing berjalan setelah tata letak diterapkan
dan menyisipkan gate seperti swap gate ke dalam circuit asli untuk membuatnya kompatibel dengan
konektivitas backend, tahap keempat adalah translation, dalam tahap ini gate-gate dalam circuit diterjemahkan ke
basis set dari backend target, berikutnya adalah optimization, tahap ini menjalankan loop optimasi utama
berulang kali sampai kondisi seperti mencapai kedalaman target tertentu terpenuhi, kita memiliki empat level optimasi berbeda
yang bisa kita pilih, terakhir adalah scheduling, tahap ini untuk pass scheduling yang sadar hardware pada
tingkat tinggi, scheduling bisa dianggap sebagai menyisipkan penundaan ke dalam circuit untuk memperhitungkan waktu idle pada qubit
di antara eksekusi instruksi, jadi seperti yang aku katakan ada empat level optimasi mulai dari 0 hingga tiga di mana
level optimasi yang lebih tinggi membutuhkan lebih banyak waktu dan upaya komputasi tapi kamu mungkin akhirnya mendapatkan circuit yang lebih baik
optimization level nol ditujukan untuk eksperimen karakterisasi perangkat dan karena itu hanya memetakan circuit input ke
kendala dari backend target, tidak melakukan optimasi apa pun, optimization level tiga
menghabiskan paling banyak upaya untuk mengoptimalkan circuit namun karena banyak teknik optimasi dalam
transpiler didasarkan pada heuristik menghabiskan lebih banyak upaya komputasi tidak selalu menghasilkan peningkatan
dalam kualitas circuit output, kalau ini menarik minat lebih lanjut silakan lihat halaman transpiler dalam dokumentasi Qiskit
yang tertaut di bawah, sekarang kita siap untuk membahas eksekusi sebenarnya dari Quantum circuit
Qiskit runtime Primitives menyediakan antarmuka ke IBM Quantum hardware dan mereka juga mengabstraksi error
suppression dan mitigation dari pengguna, sampler primitive mengembalikan distribusi quasi-probabilitas atau hitungan
yang merepresentasikan kemungkinan mengukur bit string tertentu berupa nol dan satu, estimator primitive mengembalikan nilai ekspektasi
dari observable yang sesuai dengan kuantitas fisik, jadi dalam detail sedikit lebih banyak, sampler menjalankan circuit
beberapa kali pada perangkat Quantum melakukan pengukuran pada setiap operasi dan membangun distribusi probabilitas
dari pemulihan bit string-bit string tersebut, semakin banyak operasi atau shot yang dilakukan semakin akurat hasilnya
tapi ini memerlukan lebih banyak waktu dan sumber daya Quantum yang diperlukan untuk menjalankannya, khususnya ini menghitung
probabilitas mendapatkan setiap state basis standar yang mungkin dengan mengukur state yang disiapkan oleh circuit, Qiskit
estimator menggunakan proses aljabar yang kompleks untuk memperkirakan nilai ekspektasi pada perangkat Quantum nyata dengan
memecah observable menjadi kombinasi observable lain yang memiliki basis eigen yang diketahui dan berjalan di
bawah kapnya dari Primitives adalah teknik yang disebut error mitigation, error mitigation adalah istilah umum untuk semua ini dan
pada dasarnya mengacu pada teknik yang memungkinkan kita mengurangi error circuit dengan memodelkan noise perangkat pada saat
eksekusi, biasanya ini menghasilkan overhead quantum pre-processing yang terkait dengan pelatihan model dan
overhead classical post-processing untuk memitigasi error dalam hasil mentah menggunakan model yang dihasilkan tapi sebagai imbalan dari
overhead ini kita bisa mendapatkan hasil yang jauh lebih akurat, ada beberapa teknik yang bisa kita implementasikan untuk
WEBVTT
error mitigation dan kita akan membahas tiga di antaranya secara lebih detail, perlu diketahui bahwa ini adalah area
penelitian yang aktif jadi teknik baru kemungkinan akan ditemukan dan yang lama akan terus ditingkatkan,
resilience level meningkatkan biaya atau dengan kata lain waktu yang dibutuhkan untuk menjalankan pekerjaan kamu, kita sudah mengatakan bahwa pada
resilience level nol transpiler tidak benar-benar melakukan apa pun pada circuit kamu tapi mulai dari resilience level satu ia memperkenalkan metode yang disebut twirled
readout error extinction atau kita menyebutnya T-Rex untuk singkatnya, twirled readout error extinction menggunakan Pauli twirling untuk
memitigasi noise yang merupakan sesuatu yang sudah kita singgung, ini adalah teknik yang sangat umum dan efektif yang
secara intuitif membuat noise kurang tidak teratur dan lebih mudah ditangani, mulai dari resilience level dua kita
memperkenalkan zero noise extrapolation atau ZNE untuk singkatnya, ini adalah teknik populer yang baru-baru ini kita miliki banyak
keberhasilan, ide di balik ZNE mungkin sedikit mengejutkan, kita sebenarnya menambahkan noise tambahan
di atas yang sudah ada tapi yang dilakukan ini adalah memungkinkan kita untuk mengekstrapolasi ke arah sebaliknya untuk
memprediksi seperti apa hasilnya jika ada noise yang lebih sedikit, ini bisa dilakukan dengan beberapa cara spesifik, misalnya kita
bisa meregangkan gate untuk membuatnya lebih panjang dan dengan demikian lebih rentan terhadap error atau kita bisa menjalankan lebih banyak gate yang pada akhirnya
menghasilkan operasi identitas sehingga circuit tidak benar-benar berubah secara fungsional tapi kita dengan sengaja mengambil sampel lebih banyak
noise, kamu memang harus melakukan ini untuk setiap circuit dan setiap nilai ekspektasi yang ingin kamu lacak meski begitu jadi kamu
bisa melihat betapa mahalnya dalam hal waktu yang dibutuhkan, satu jenis spesifik dari ZNE disebut
probabilistic error amplification atau PEA untuk singkatnya, setelah kita mempelajari model noise untuk gate, PEA bekerja dengan mengambil sampel
error dari model noise itu dan dengan sengaja menyuntikkannya ke dalam circuit, seperti yang aku sebutkan banyak teknik baru
terus dikembangkan dan semoga akan diimplementasikan seiring kita melihat semakin banyak yang masuk, hanya ada satu bentuk akhir dari
error mitigation yang ingin aku bahas yang disebut probabilistic error cancellation, alih-alih berada di resilience
level ketiga, PEC adalah kemampuan khusus yang harus kamu aktifkan secara manual di Qiskit karena sumber daya komputasi
yang dibutuhkan tidak skalanya tidak terlalu baik dibandingkan dengan teknik error mitigation lain yang telah kita bahas, kamu
mulai dengan mempelajari tentang noise yang mempengaruhi circuit kamu dengan menjalankan noise learning atau noise characterization
circuit untuk setiap layer unik dari gate dua qubit yang ada dalam circuit kamu, hasil-hasil ini memungkinkan kamu mendeskripsikan noise
dalam hal operator Pauli, setelah kamu mengetahui suku-suku noise ini kamu bisa memodifikasi circuit kamu sehingga
mereka secara efektif memiliki PEC terbalik yang dibangun untuk membatalkan saluran noise ini, dalam beberapa hal proses ini
mirip dengan noise-cancelling headphone, namun cara membatalkan noise ini sangat mahal dengan waktu untuk
dijalankan yang bertumbuh secara eksponensial dengan jumlah gate jadi mungkin bukan pilihan terbaik untuk circuit yang sangat besar, kita
sekarang telah mencapai tahap akhir yaitu post-processing, pada akhirnya kalau kamu sudah melakukan pekerjaan yang baik dan menggunakan teknik error
mitigation yang tepat kamu mungkin melihat jawaban akhirmu bergeser seperti dalam gambar ini di sini, distribusi yang tidak dimitigasi
ditunjukkan dalam ungu cukup jauh dari nilai ekspektasi sebenarnya yang ditunjukkan di sini oleh garis ini, namun setelah kita menerapkan error
mitigation kita mendapatkan distribusi yang dimitigasi yang ditunjukkan di sini dalam biru yang puncaknya jauh lebih dekat ke nilai sesungguhnya, sekarang
ini semua memiliki biaya dan di sini kita bisa melihat bahwa variance atau lebar dari distribusi meningkat yang
umumnya bukan yang kamu inginkan tapi segalanya ada harganya, untungnya kita bisa memperhitungkan ini dengan menjalankan lebih banyak
shot yang menyebabkan distribusi menyusut kembali ke tingkat ketidakpastian yang dapat diterima, jadi itu kira-kira semuanya untuk
pelajaran ini, untuk berikutnya kita akan mengambil semua langkah ini dan menyatukannya dan mengerjakan sebuah area dan contoh
dari minat aplikasi nyata, ada beberapa hal yang bisa aku rekomendasikan untuk kita lakukan sampai saat itu, kalau kamu belum
pastikan kamu mengunduh dan mengatur Qiskit 1.0, kamu juga bisa melihat pelajaran terkait untuk bab ini dan
episode sebelumnya di platform IBM Quantum learning dan terakhir kalau kamu memiliki minat untuk menggali lebih dalam dan
mempelajari lebih lanjut tentang teknik error mitigation lihat salah satu dari banyak sumber yang aku tautkan di bawah, sampai saat itu kita sampai jumpa lagi
[Music]